welcome back to cbs this morning chicago
is temporarily delaying part of its
return
to in-person learning after the teachers
union there threatened to strike over
safety concerns
during this pandemic it's all part of a
national debate about reopening schools
in which the teachers
are often caught between their love for
the class and fears about their own
health and the health of their own
students
meg oliver has the story we have to
count
patti wagner is in her 17th year
teaching special ed students in a
low-income neighborhood of chicago
it's her passion my students are
my breath the veteran teacher is worried
about her students well-being
and plans to return to school in person
as soon as possible
why do you want to go back to in-person
teaching it's the classroom
you know you the remote teaching is was
interesting
challenging and necessary so i mastered
it right but i'm in my dining room
that's not my home turf
chicago mayor lori lightfoot says the
city has spent roughly 100 million
dollars
on ventilation masks and safety
protocols
but last week more than 70 percent of
union members voted against returning to
the classroom
including preschool teacher vanessa
saucedo
we had a significant number of families
that were affected
by death from covid as well as just
entire households that got sick
corey de angelis with the recent
foundation a libertarian think tank
has been studying the link between
unions and reopening schools
he looked at more than 800 school
districts and found the stronger the
teachers union the less likely a school
will reopen in person
and covet 19 risks were not always the
only part
of the equation not because they're bad
people there's a lot of good people in
the teachers union and
in the public school system it's because
of the incentives
they get to stay home and retain the
same amount of benefits
and pay and job security demands from
teachers unions have become big sticking
points in negotiations
in chicago the union has raised concerns
about remote work requests
being denied and teachers in los angeles
say
being vaccinated isn't safe enough they
want to see coveted rates drop
before they return to the classroom the
president of the country's largest
teachers union
becky pringle says safety is their top
priority
do you believe teachers unions are
becoming scapegoats in this debate to
reopen schools
people are frightened they're scared
when that happens when people come from
a place of fear
they start to blame other people with
this national debate causing a clear
divide in the education community
teachers like wagner are saying it's the
students who are suffering
both organizations need to come to some
kind of settlement
that involves safety for children for
cbs this morning
meg oliver i mean i've said this before
my wife's a teacher i i hear about this
all day
every day the teachers are really
worried it's that simple
they want to be safe they want the kids
to be safe um
you know the unions are strong and
they're they're trying to work for the
teachers but i promise you
every teacher wants to be back in school
i was going to say that all the teachers
all wanted they don't want to be in
their dining room no they're kitchen tv
no and then or
back in the littlest room in the house
where my wife is every day but
but they want to be safe because very
often they have people at home who are
vulnerable
and they don't want to bring it back to
them well said